CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here to try and break
down what the tax bill could mean for
families Jill good morning this is so
important let's talk about how do they
affect individual families first so it's
really important to understand that this
is a bill that is very nuanced so it
matters not just who you are and how
much money you earn but how do you earn
that money do you have a pass-through
organization or do you live in a state
where you're losing your state and local
tax deduction do you have a mortgage how
much do you want it so it's a very
strange bill in that in the past when
we've done tax reform and tax deductions
and unfortunately I remember 30 years
ago it was a much clearer this is a
winner this is a loser this is gonna
take a long time to really understand
who wins and who loses okay the big
differences in the two plans
well the big differences are going down
we know that the tax brackets are very
important so in the house plan they have
four tax brackets they maintain that top
bracket at 39.6 the Senate plan I'm
sorry the house plan goes to four
brackets in the Senate plan maintains
seven brackets but the top bracket goes
down mortgage interest deduction house
plan says you can only deduct up to a
half a million of mortgage interest the
Senate plan says no we're gonna leave it
at a million and what we really know the
big huge change in the tax code is
around corporations in corporations they
both are slashing the corporate rate it
goes from thirty five to twenty percent
go ahead the tax cuts historically are
very popular with both Republicans and
Democrats this one is at thirty percent
approval why do you think so many
Americans disapprove of this tax cut I
think it's becoming clear that it's very
much tilted towards corporations and the
wealthiest Americans you know if you're
upper-middle class you could actually be
a loser in this bill and that's very
important to put out there and if you're
the very poor you could be a loser and I
think when Americans hear that
corporations which have seen great
profitability over the last seven years
stock markets at all-time highs it's
hard to really understand in your belly
why do those corporations need this tax
cut tax reform is one thing making a tax
code better simple
planar but an actual gift to
corporations at a moment where we are
right now second longest bull market in
the history of the United States economy
it's hard to reconcile that it still
seems very confusing even the people
that passed it are still trying to fit
read it and figure out exactly what they
passed so who really wins and who loses
I heard you talking about two losing
situation so who are the winners here
well I think if you are the tenth of 1%
of an earner you are a huge winner
because we're gonna get rid of estate
taxation
the tax brackets are gonna go down I
think those people win I think
corporations huge winners pass through
organizations that means you've got a
big law firm there's 200 partners they
have all their money flows through it's
a pass-through that is going to be a big
winner whether those folks who are
winners
then take the money that they save and
recycle it into the economy and boost
the economy substantially I think that
is a huge question yet to be answered a
lot of academics say they don't believe
this is a long-term growth incentive
Randall Stephens of the head of AT&T has
promised more jobs I mean you have some
CEOs on the record promising
reinvestment so we'll see where they
come up with those jobs Joe thank you so
much